[Musique]
début 2016
le porte avions charles de gaulle est en
mer depuis déjà quelques mois on a
appareillé juste après les attentats du
bataclan et je suis actuellement avec un
équipier quelque part au dessus de
l'irak aux commandes de rafale marine
on ne part jamais seul au combat
l'individualité n'a pas sa place que ce
soit au sol sur le champ de bataille ou
dans les airs
même si on est à plus de 5 km des
affrontements il ya environ cinq heures
on a été catapulté du charles de gaulle
passant de 0 km heure à plus de 250 km
heure en 75 m depuis on a effectué plus
de trois ravitaillements en vol
récupérant l'équivalent d'une centaine
de plants de carburant pour votre
voiture
en seulement une dizaine de minutes on
est actuellement à 4700 mètres au dessus
du nord de l'irak
il ya quelques minutes on nous a demandé
de traiter un mortier qui tirait sur des
troupes alliées je profite d'une légère
réduction de la charge de travail dans
le cockpit pour me remémorer les actions
de la patrouille lors de cette attaque
ça me sera utile lorsqu'on sera de
retour sur le porte-avions et qu'il
faudra débriefer nos actions donc
débriefer pour prendre un jeune
bachelier ont fait un pilote de chasse
apte à aller au combat en moins de cinq
ans il n'y a pas de recette miracle il
faut le former et la manière de le
former chez nous et bien c'est de
débriefer soyez persuadés qu'ils
auraient ni aviation navale ni à ponte
âge ni ni opérations et suprématie
aérienne si on effectue est passé
débriefing mais qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un débriefing un débriefing c'est une
recherche
après l'action pour essayer de se
remémorer toutes et toutes les choses
qu'on a faites et identifier des points
perfectibles de manière à s'améliorer
d'un vol sur l'autre c'est un processus
qu'on répète jour après jour mois après
mois après après année
j'ai effectué en 13 ans tu 3000
débriefing 3000 certains ont duré dix
minutes
d'autres une demi-heure après chaque
mission de combat ont débrief après
chaque mission d'entraînement on débrief
et l'objectif c'est donc se remémorer ce
qui s'est passé identifier le résultat
de manière quantifiable
on essaye de travailler en pourcentage
analyser comment on en est arrivé là
identifier les erreurs qui ont été
faites et s'est trouvé des parades pour
ne plus les reproduire et ensuite
identifié ce qu'on appelle des lawson
learn les lots sunsern
c'est des enseignements qui sont
tellement importants qu'il faut s'en
rappeler après la mission mais qui
méritent également d'être partagée avec
le reste de la communauté
des fois c'est l'automne n'ayant vont
nous faire changer les procédures
manière de fonctionner on part d'un
postulat de base extrêmement simple dans
l'aviation
on vit pas assez longtemps pour faire
toutes les erreurs nous mêmes donc il
est indispensable de communiquer au sein
de l'équipe au sein de la patrouille
il nous reste sept bombes de 250 kilos
deux cent cinquante obus de 30 mm qui
font 450 grammes chacun est également
plusieurs missiles air-air on est à
l'écouté de trois fréquences radios
différentes en même temps une avec le
contrôle aérien
une avec les troupes au sol et une qu'on
appelle l'inter patrouille entre leaders
et équipier on s'apprête à remettre cap
vers le sud pour rejoindre le
porte-avions lorsqu à ce moment là on
nous appelle sur la fréquence numéro
deux seuls avec les troupes au sol des
marines américains sont en train de se
faire tirer dessus
c'est une embuscade il ya plusieurs
sniper qui les prennent à partie ils ont
besoin d'appui aérien immédiat c'est ma
patrie de la plus proche
on a environ 150 km tout de suite on met
cap dessus on accélère il faut aller les
aider à ce moment là le stress est à son
maximum
la charge de travail est également à son
maximum il faut refaire tous les calculs
pétrole trouver un nouvel avion
ravitailleur est également prévenir le
porte-avions qu'on sera pas là à l'heure
prévue
mais qu'on va avoir du retard et être
apte à quantifier ce retard pour les
aider à s'organiser israël et se
réorienter pour la suite des activités
aériennes
il faut également que j'explique à mon
équipier l'idée de manoeuvre demers
qu'on puisse travailler avec la
meilleure synergie possible et être le
plus efficace possible rapidement
passant fréquences avec les troupes au
sol
la nuit en train de tomber les
conditions sont très difficiles et la
zone à couvrir est extrêmement vaste
après quelques minutes on arrive à
localiser un sniper et un observateur on
se présente pour une première passe de
tirs buts
quelques minutes plus tard on arrive à
identifier un deuxième style peur on le
traite également les marines se
reprennent leur avancée la mission
accomplie notre côté on part en haut et
on va récupérer un avion ravitailleur
qui va nous accompagner jusqu'au golfe
persique pour rejoindre le dernier avion
ravitailleur on le rallye c'est à dire
qu'on vient se mettre en patrouille
serré à quelques mètres de lui de nuit
de manière à pouvoir voler proche de lui
c'est ce qu'on appelle le vol en
formation
quand on apprend le vol en formation nos
instructeurs nous communique deux choses
primordiales
la première c'est la méthode faut être
au bon étagement au bon retrait et au
bon écartement pour pouvoir tenir sa
position de jour comme de nuit les
allocs là où même sur le dos la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il faut être très souple
au niveau de la main parce que le
pilotage se fait via la main droite est
le seul moyen d'éliminer ces tensions
sans être abruptes aux commandes
et bien c'est d'évacuer toute cette
tension en bougeant des doigts de pied
donc dans l'avion là on voit pas non en
train de bouger les doigts de pieds ça
permet de se détendre et c'est très
efficace croyez moi pourquoi est-ce que
je vous parle du vol en formation
parce que si on n'est pas déjà au bon
étagement puits obo rentrée puis au bon
écartement ça ne marche pas et cette
philosophie de séquençage on l'appliqué
dans d'autres domaines
quand vous partez faire une en vols de
7h au dessus de l'irak vous découper ses
missions mentalement
vous avez la préparation de mission la
réflexion sur les cas non conformes
vous avez le briefing l'habillement la
mise en route le roulage le catapultage
le transit aller le premier
ravitaillement
le deuxième ravitaillement ensuite vous
avez la partie sur zone peut-être les
frappes à l'armement laser les frappes à
l'armement guider gps le transit retour
le ravitaillement de nuit l'appontage et
le débriefing
vous avez tout découpé en une multitude
de petites taches
c'est exactement pareil que si demain
vous allez courir un marathon et que
vous dites je vais commencer mon
marathon par un semi-marathon de 21 km
que j'ai déjà fait plein de fois
l'entraînement ou fois que j'ai fini ça
j'enchaîne sur un 10 km puis sur 1,7 km
puis sur une petite course de 3 km et je
finis par kilomètre finale facile
mentalement c'est beaucoup plus simple à
visualiser et vous irez de petite
victoire en petite victoire
c'est comme si vous montez démarche vers
le sommet de la colline plutôt que vous
retrouvez en bas de la falaise et
regarder ça d'un coup en vous disant
c'est impossible ça passera pas beaucoup
ça ça fait 7 heures qu'on est dans
l'avion
alors imaginez un paris new york assis
sur votre chaise journée en classe éco
dans l'avion de ligne sans amoureux de
retirer votre ceinture avec un gros
casque sur la tête pointe depuis que
j'ai fait la guerre en irak je trouve le
confort de l'aviation ning beaucoup
beaucoup mieux
il va falloir rejoindre le porte-avions
la charge de travail assez faible durant
cette dernière heure de transit et là le
piège c'est l'hypovigilance qu'il faut
se rappeler pourquoi on est là et la
mission n'est pas terminée
la mission de ce sera fini qu'une fois
qu'on aura affronté avec nos deux
aéronefs qu'on les aura rendus aux
mécaniciens et qu'on aura débriefer la
mission on a un dicton dans l'aviation
chasse celle où sight lose the fight
si en combat aérien vous perdez le
visuel de votre adversaire
il va vous tuer action réaction mais ce
que ça veut vraiment dire c'est que si
vous perdez votre objectif de vue vous
n'allez pas pouvoir réussir la mission
donc il est indispensable de constamment
se demander est ce que je suis aligné à
mon objectif ou plutôt quel est mon
objectif
ou quelles sont mes objectifs à court
moyen et long terme
or ce questionnement nécessite une prise
de recul
il ya une grande compagnie
nord-américaine qui a demandé c'est quoi
au nom de bord durant plusieurs années
qu en cas de panne si ça ne nécessitait
pas une réaction immédiate de leur part
et bien qu'ils reculent physiquement
leur siège de manière à pouvoir avoir un
vrai recul à la fois physique et
psychologique mieux analyser les
événements et mieux hiérarchiser les
priorités
on se prépare donc à l'appontage de nuit
on va arriver avec un avion qui fait à
peu près la masse d'un bûcher l'inertie
d'un bus qui se déplace en trois
dimensions à 75 mètres par seconde et on
va essayer d'accrocher un des trois
brins d'arrêt donc c'est à peu près
comme visé le filet d'un terrain de
tennis de nuit en haute mer et ya tout
qui bouge votre terrain de tennis se
déplace à 35 à 40 km heure où on dit que
c'est pas un sport de masse et je vous
arrête tout de suite il ya pas davantage
automatique dans l'aéronavale
par contre on a une prime de risque donc
on a ponte posez pas cassé c'est
l'expression consacrée
derrière on débrief et une fois qu'on a
fini le débriefing de l'équipage eh bien
on va faire une réunion avec tous les
officiers du bord et on va discuter
naulleau sunsern
qu'est ce que cette mission nous a
appris et en quoi est-ce que ça peut
leur être bénéfique
on a eu de la chance ce jour là pas sa
mission s'est bien passé
en aéronautique comme dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est pas toujours le cas
le 29 décembre 1972 un nouvel eastern
airlines 401 devait relier new york à
miami avec un avion lookheed l'équipage
était très confirmée elle veut un
commandant de bord un co pilote un
mécanicien navigant et même un
technicien de l'accompagner dans le
cockpit alors qu'il était en approche
sur miami
au moment de sortir un train
d'atterrissage une des langues ne s'est
pas allumé que ma devraient ils ont donc
décidé d'aller se mettre en attente ou
de suie des marais des everglades qui
sont très sombres
il était presque minuit ils sont mis à
600 mètres d'altitude sont rendus compte
qu'en fait une ampoule été cassé donc le
copilote a essayé de démonter lampoon
pour pouvoir procéder au changement
il n'y arrivait pas le commandant de
bord a essayé de l'aider le mécanicien
navigant également tout le monde était
occupée est accaparée par ce changement
dans pool qui était en fait plus
difficile qu'on m'avait l'air sans faire
exprès le commandant de bord a touché le
manche qui a désactivé plus automatiques
et ce qui a mis l'avion digne dans une
légère descente l'alarmé a sonné mais
personne ne l'a entendu le contrôle
aérien s'en est rendu compte
leur a demandé si tout allait bien à
bord réponse de l'équipage tout est ok
on sera bientôt prêt pour la proche 20
secondes après ça le copilote s'est
rendu compte qu'il ya quelque chose
d'anormal
trop tard une vision d'après ils ont
impacté les marais sur les
176 personnes à bord sans n'ont pas
survécu au crash l'avion était tout neuf
ils étaient quatre dans le cockpit et
l'avion est en parfait état
seule une ampoule à moins d'un dollar
était défectueuse ils étaient tous
tellement manipulé par cette tâche
simple qu'ils ont oublié leurs objectifs
à long terme qui était d'amener l'avion
les passagers en toute sécurité à miami
luis ait loser fight dans l'aviation on
appelle cela tunnelisation alors
pourquoi ce terme de tunnellisation
parce que les symptômes qu'on ressent
c'est un peu comme si on était
prisonnier d'un long tunnel très long et
très étroit et notre cerveau reptilien
nous fait croire que l'unique sortie se
trouve tout au bout et qu'il faut y
aller le plus vite possible
on a également des soucis auditifs quand
on est dans ce tunnel
le son ne se propage pas de manière
normale et on perd beaucoup notre vision
périphérique
ça devient extrêmement dur d'analyser
notre environnement tout autour à l'air
sombre et 3 on perd notre capacité de
prise de recul et notre charge de
travail est complètement saturé n'en a
pas conscience c'est insidieux
donc on sait même pas qu'on devrait
demander de l'aide dans l'aviation de
chasse sur mono classe quand la charge
de travail devient énorme
on a une méthode très simple et très
efficace pour lutter contre et
finalisation
on va séquences et nos tâches on va
débriefer de manière rapide et régulière
et on va s'assurer dans notre parfaite
alignement aux objectifs à court moyen
et long terme
j'ai récemment quitté le monde de
l'aviation de chasse pour
l'entrepreneuriat et le consulting
je suis forcément demander en quoi ma
première carrière pourrait m'être utile
pour la suite je me suis rendu compte
que de nombreuses technologies utilisées
dans l'armée et est désormais utilisé
dans un monde civil la nourriture sous
conserve nous vient de l'armée
napoléonienne
le gps qu'on utilise tous c'est depuis
1996 utile au civil grâce à bill clinton
les montre qu'on a tous au poignet ça a
également été inventé pour les
militaires et maintenant c'est fait
partie de notre quotidien
mais réduire les méthodes militaires à
de la technologie je trouvais sympa pas
honnête
parce qu'en fait unités de chasse aux
combats reposent plus sur la somme des
individualités
que sur cette technologie chaque marin
est aligné vers l'objectif final qui est
la réussite de la mission et chaque
marin utilise les mêmes méthodes et
soumis aux mêmes risques et ses méthodes
sont transférables dans le civil donc
voyez l'aviation embarquée non pas comme
un vecteur de puissance militaire et
politique mais plutôt comme une
organisation complexe qui a recours à
des méthodes pour été prouvée au combat
et qui peuvent vous être utile que ce
soit de manière privée ou
professionnelle
vous avez des soucis de couple vous avez
des soucis d'argent
si vous voulez reprendre les études
si vous avez votre enfant de 5 ans qui
d'un coup au mieux du supermarché se met
à vous faire une énorme crise j'ai connu
ça et bien les moyens pour tuner lisez
en fait sont présents au quotidien donc
que ce soit seul en couple ou en équipe
rappelez-vous ceux ci
rappelez-vous ce si on est tous aux
commandes de notre propre monoplace et
sans vous il n'y a pas de commandant de
bord donc n'allait pas au crash
séquences et vos tâches débriefer reste
est aligné à vos objectifs et tout se
passera bien merci